there you go there you go there you go
back to us here yeah I'm doing I don't
believe me I'll do a selfie here we go
my name is
for inventing lstm it stands for long
short-term memory this is where we are
in times where our neural networks have
to pull neurons one layer
and could not memorize anything
and now I'm well known for LSM and it's
a Vanishing gradient finishing gradient
is a problem wide deep
neural networks did not work yes and
again I'm here at new reps after uh many
many years and enjoying it and whom I
met is Tim I'm so happy to meet you it's
such an honor to me honestly and we've
been trying to get you on the show
actually we have actually had some
communication and it's good that we
actually meet in person because it's
much better by chance uh only by pure
chance we're just walking past each
other what are your predictions for AGI
first of all I'm not sure whether I will
I will not live uh long enough uh uh my
first critic is uh the definition is
very human-centered yeah because we are
so uh uh proud and uh also against this
everything is intelligent what we as
human do and uh
um general intelligence could be
completely different server to see it to
Define it is the first problem well can
I can I pressure you on that so you know
there are different ways of defining it
based on function capability Behavior
principle
Etc
um which definition do you use
uh yeah normally you do it for AGI for
uh uh human level intelligence and
that's what humans do planning learning
oh so that's a functional definition
yeah very similar to Chalmers actually
yeah but we can you can also uh divide
it by a skill accusation yes stuff like
this like show like actually
and related he's very smart and I love
him in my my short paper I recite him
all the time yes because he brought into
a notion of a broad AI yes and that's I
like it much more we have an arrow AI a
broad AI uh is much uh has much more
skills can acquire skills easier with of
your samples and stuff like this yeah
right but it's not defined by our human
capabilities uh it's defined by uh yeah
a skill appreciation or solving tasks I
completely agree so so I I share
sholay's um skepticism that being able
to do one task really well is the same
thing as intelligence I think
generalization or skill acquisition
efficiency as a first-class citizen is
really really important so yes I
completely agree with you on that well I
can give you a thing what's missing
today yeah uh all uh absolutely uh up
selection we have comes from humans Isis
comes from speech Yes why we keep labels
that's a uh there uh uh care the dog we
have done this even if you don't give a
label we send this object in the middle
and the room is already has this thing
in the middle is something
recognized yes and on abstraction what I
see in deep learning in AI Community
comes from Human what I want to see said
abstraction abstract Concepts evolving
from CCI systems yes I don't know
whether we can see it perhaps don't
recognize them but right now everything
comes from Human I completely okay again
I completely agree so all of the
abstractions we have now in large
language models for example are
crystallized instances of humans making
that obstruction yes so so then we get
to the to the definition of what it is
for a category or an abstraction you
know Douglas hofstadter has this idea of
of analogy making is being very
important but what exactly does it mean
to create an analogy well uh analogy or
an abstraction you see some common
components common structures common
processes on a higher level if you pull
stuff together then you see assistant
this is the same uh if uh we pull stuff
together uh if we say uh this state
assist objects are the same and so best
thing is mathematics if an X
an X stands for many many numbers and
you do app selection because you do it
for all numbers at once so that's a high
level of physical uh laws uh uh you know
for mass and it works for a pen for a
ball for whatever use it's the highest
level of abstractions we have many many
many
objects things items are covered by this
very abstract rules yes I I completely
agree but and similar to how
conjecturing Works in mathematics that's
right it's similar to creativity itself
and the problem is when you create
abstractions you're selecting from an
infinite set of possible objects yeah so
how could that possibly be represented
in in a finite computation
I don't know I think you always explore
a little bit uh your environment you
don't see everything and you go only one
step further which is new and then uh
discovers uh something new because once
up further uh brings you in a situation
which is similar somehow to a situation
you know from South Carolina is I think
you don't see all the space
the only locally explores the space a
little bit okay and one of the things
that I try to to understand is is the
representation is different now
different levels of analysis so for
example if you look at the concept of um
even causality is a great example
depending on the microscopic level or
the macroscopic level yes the the
observables or the objects are
completely different so it's almost like
the thing I can't get my head around is
inside a predictive model where does
that structure come from
I don't know about uh or whether I'll
get you right a predictive model gets an
input like like an image or uh well I
guess I'm saying that
um we're talking about the complex
phenomenon of lots of different things
like causality and the level of
resolution determines the representation
yes right so we almost need to I mean I
know Jan Lagoon spoke about this in his
uh path to autonomous intelligence paper
where he's talking about we need to have
an abstraction hierarchy where we can
work at different levels
completely yeah yeah because here again
one picture from another pixel or one uh
a cent coin for uh how it's moving yeah
but uh sometimes we want to see whether
a lens light a whole bunch of uh fonts
uh move uh so you have as a physical
laws are you pull the stuff together and
this is what I think is the abstraction
yeah getting to more more things uh
you're more abstract is more
situation objects or whatever can be
covered by this one loss is one ideas is
one few interesting so on on that then
are you a blank slave person or do you
think our predictive architectures need
to have a great number of worldly priors
to understand the you know the reality
uh I think
uh humans need a strong prior because we
have it from our society we have for our
parents we'll learn it in school we
don't we run everything from the
beginning uh if you want to learn it
from scratch
I still believe you need strong priors I
don't think there's enough data sense
that you can discover everything by your
own
and uh our priors are given by Society
our brothers are given by education our
price are given by our parents but we
have very very strong Brothers okay and
what do you think about discrete versus
continuous do you think there are
certain classes of problems that might
be more amenable to say discrete program
search than neural networks uh I think
we humans can only think in discrete
thing we cannot think continuously uh
everything is discrete on discreetness
you need also for abstraction because
this treatment all these objects are the
same
so continuous stuff I I think is
completion is an illusion wow so I'm
really surprised to hear you say that
this is really interesting so so yeah so
first of all an extension of what you've
said is you think that we think
symbolically so um similarly to Fodor
argued that you know the whole
compositionality is a way of reducing
the infinite cardinality of the world
that we live in so we kind of do
symbolic quantification variables so you
think that's how we were but but then
how does the neural net Works fit in
here because I don't think they support
that kind of reasoning yeah
completely different and I think I'm not
sure about this as I do it right right
because that's uh also said drawbacks I
can do very precise computations but
this ability makes him weak because I
can less generalize saying hey I don't
care has this length of this length it's
small so this length is a large but as I
really very precisely computers and
perhaps that's wrong perhaps I should do
a categorization uh discretization very
early on and then have better
abstraction because that's the answer a
final rule don't need this resolution
also neural networks are Computing right
now fascinating okay and out of all of
the research topics that are in Vogue at
the moment which ones are most
interesting to you for me it's uh right
now answered because
Jose's big models uh this Foundation
models hacking phase uh it's a big thing
but uh if you download them you don't
know uh how good is your prediction
should you I rely on it what is my data
point different from the data points I
have trained on yes and now we're
looking into before downloader model can
adjust the prediction yeah how reliable
is it yeah it's making a little bit
around what's happening is there a
different explanation you see it as a
different models we call it administrial
models not that we're serial examples at
your certain models if you give me water
this I can give you if you want to
switch tell you a completely opposite
Ivan and uh you shouldn't believe as a
prediction so there's a few places we
can go there first of all I agree with
you the uncertainty quantification is
really really important and I'm inspired
by Jan Lagoon's work with the
energy-based models which is a way of
making a track yes what you also said
was something along the lines of
interpretability counterfactual analysis
having like these rich models to allow
you to do diagnostics because what do
you think about the black box nature of
of machine learning do you think that as
we were just describing
um imputing some human intelligible
structure is actually the way to go yeah
well probably I give you an example what
I think is this great in descent what we
are using right now back propagation
yeah clear
getting the same Basin of Attraction
because if there's one very strong input
feature you would suck it out at the
beginning use it to reduce the error
yeah but there could be really large
modes Solutions which are hidden by you
because you're very greedy it's a great
and it's all neural networks in the same
direction yes but perhaps two bigger
features would do better and therefore
to find this modes which perhaps
generalize better
uh we have to impute some biases and we
have to give prior knowledge some hints
or perhaps even Explore
amazing
um Seth thank you so much I really
appreciate your time